this is the clover it's a coffee maker
that works sort of like a cross between
a French press and a vacuum pot uses
sort of the best of both worlds the way
it works is you dump your coffee grounds
into the top side of this machine here
this chamber lowers hot water rushes out
and it brews for just a really quick
less than one minute time it depends on
the coffee when it finishes brewing the
elevator lowers again and it creates a
vacuum that sucks the coffee through
this little 70 micron filter when the
coffee gets down here it just comes out
of this little spigot here and you've
got yourself a fresh individually brewed
cup now the machine itself cost eleven
thousand dollars which sounds expensive
but basically what you're paying for is
a team of Stanford engineers to build
this thing by hand you're also paying to
get a individually crafted cup unlike a
French press or a vacuum pot you can
design a specific brew cycle for the
beans that you're going to brew so if
I'm going to brew one of these nice cup
of excellent winner San Jose beans I can
take my
pull over here and program in a brew
time brew temperature and how many grams
of coffee I'm using and it'll give me a
custom brew that wouldn't be able to get
with say a French press or a vacuum pot
another way it beats the French press is
it doesn't leave the sediment in that
you get that on a French press you push
the coffee down the bloom or the grounds
down through the coffee and then you
pour it a lot of times you'll get some
sediment your cup this doesn't do that
now Starbucks just bought the company so
you're not going to be able to get any
more clovers unless you work in a
Starbucks store right now there are
about 250 machines that are in the
marketplace and other than those unless
you're somewhere like ritual that has
four of them you're not going to get any
more now Starbucks has bought all these
machines and the question for them is
can they get the beans to go in it
Starbucks isn't known for having the
best quality beans a lot of people say
they over roast or that they they're
being sit around too long or they're
over there too much blends instead of
single origins I guess we're going to
have to wait and see Starbucks says
they're going to get better beans but
who knows
you
[Music]